massimo naveau éditorialiste pour le
quotidien italien corriere della sera
mona bas bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
avec le feu vert de bruxelles l'italie
et bien donc de bloquer deux cent
cinquante mille doses du vaccin
astrazeneca didot ce qui devait arriver
orne australie comment cette décision a
été perçue en italie bien évidement
beaucoup apprécié l'initiative de mme
alliot la guinée notre nouveau première
un sien présidente de la bce et parce
que en fait des îles à l'initiative de
rupture avec certaines laxité un certain
automatisme d accord international de la
boule au crédit et aux voies bien
qu'étant en initiative politique très
forte un bref message qui évoque si vous
voulez un peu web et ex le port de 2 de
la crise de l'eurozone et c'est la route
différente et ma démarche nous plus
proche à aller réel besoin de la
population pas seulement italienne main
général européen de voir que c'est
toujours les compliments de l'arrière 2
du monde
touché dans l'académie par contre des
pays comme avec romain l'australie vous
l'avez évoqué quelques uns des 101
d'écart donc c'est pas le cas mais en
même temps c'est paradoxal de voir
avec tous les déclarations qui sont
suivis dans certaines dans les dernières
heures depuis hier et qu'il s'agit en
fait d'un template un verre d'eau parce
que l' australie a tout de suite déclaré
qu est bon et bien d'accord il comprend
très bien le disent et ibn le premièr
italienne la france coule comme vous
l'avez dit indiqué pourrait faire la
même chose euros à la commission
européenne approuve et l'ont publié ce
matin
anita view des démarches de bédard le
président de dpd alors tendrement
européenne le représentant sud de
l'allemagne qui dit victime e
annie a parfaitement raison à ça
leur seule critique il ya un peu de la
grande bretagne
parce qu'en fait sont un peu les patrons
d'astrazeneca certaine manière et et
évoque encore une fois c'est qu'il
ressemble la démarche ce moment sur la
question de gaza il ya un esprit très
pragmatique dans la recherche est aussi
dans la distribution de baisser dans la
part des pays comme les etats unis la
grande bretagne et aussi israël et enfin
il faut être objectivement non plus de
résultat plus importantes sur la
distribution sur la bastille nation de
la population et un côté un peu
bureaucratique un peu juridique un peu
inégal si vous venez de tous les pays de
la communauté européenne et de la
commission européenne
je pense que mario draghi l'initiative
de rompre avec ça avec dans des
motivations textuellement légal mais on
a des initiatives politiques sinon sur
le central et n'est pas considéré comme
un pays vulnérable en face à l'épidémie
de coronavirus on sait que laboratoire
astrazeneca fait part de retards
d'approvisionnement de production est un
moyen finale
de faire pression sur les laboratoires
pour avoir l es12 deux actions au plus
vite et honorer leur contrat mais ma
stratégie de ça ces paradoxes a aussi
indiqué qu'on tente personnellement les
raisons des gouvernements italien donc
essaiera une suite d d d assurer des
cernéens partie des doses puis ça les
pays vulnérables pays qui ont beaucoup
plus besoin de ça il faut pas oublier
aussi qu'il n'y ait été dans les
dernières semaines que la victime d'un
communication dans l'erreur des
communications très très compliqué parce
que tout le monde pensait que les
bassins des pikes héros moderne au même
les spoutniks russe était plus efficace
surtout dans la population de plus de 65
ans et après le lourd en jour on dit bon
tous les bassins sont bons tout le
bassin sont équivalentes
donc il faut faire aussi la vaccination
gavi est un peu saccadée est performant
dans le nord sous le clan de là si vous
voulez de l'inde et la facilité de la
distribution et de stockage parce qu'on
ne peut pas oublier que x11 doit être
conservée à des températures très très
bas et donc pas tous les structures et
les moyens de faire ça tu as tu as des
as et un bassin très normal donc très
faste il a donné des festivals
distribués mais encore je répète à la
fin tout est d'accord elle deux matches
ça savait pas la danse parce que même à
peut bel et bien dit le son est déjà
fait des déclarations d'hier soir leaké
bon et comprends parfaitement la
position de l'italie
donc en fait de monsieur dick et a pris
l'initiative
merci beaucoup en tout cas un maximum
nava d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
pour le quotidien italien corriere delle